haier moments and dress moments and leg
moments and shoe moments it was a
glamour moment first moment
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
how did you happen to get the name wrong
it's from a song in the I guess it was a
movie paint your wagon my mom liked it
and she tells me she thought it would be
like a good stage name I guess she maybe
had a plan or something my mother is
Irish my father is black and Venezuelan
and my color is tan I don't know which
one are you gonna put I don't know
because I don't have a mantle or
anything so I guess I put him on my
shelf and I don't really get a chance to
see the fans and the people you know
that have supported me and bought my
album so it felt really great I got
really emotional about it no pun
intended
in the Robins called emotions
[Music]
so scary I mean I I thank God that I
didn't faint when I saw Rita Franklin in
the front row and Patti LaBelle I mean
and Barbra Streisand lurking somewhere
in the house
I mean I grew up in New York I'm from
New York you know when I was struggling
I lived in New York and I used to dream
about performing here at Madison Square
Garden doing it tonight
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay this is my first announcement of a
new baby you just want you guys to see
it
psych this is my new puppy we haven't
named her yet she's really really sleepy
my makeup artist wants me to color girl
but but you can't really just color girl
you have to be like girl
and it was the end of the day
so I really froze my little
they wrote something that I never show
one side of my face I have a scar or
something that it so this is my other
side okay calm down I'm alive don't
close up on it now I have to that was a
lovely bit of trivia song can you t'get
some Japanese can I teach et some
Japanese I'm not exactly the best
authority on the Japanese language but
now let's see what did I learn I shoulda
must that means I love you
Ward's of paparazzi and fans surrounding
in lots of blinding lights and cameras
it's very overwhelming the most
important thing for me is to touch and
see and connect with the fans that have
waited for hours to see me he's and then
my security points now don't go over
there but you know I can't I can't
neglect the people that make me
successful I love this dress this is the
Gucci little Gucci number and I guess I
feel semi sexy but you know I don't want
to say that because they're going over
with these rumors about me and everybody
Under the Sun so I don't want act like
I'm some new sex bomb Queen can you
believe this every time I see you guys
I'm like going in a helicopter riding
daredevil riding horseback tricks this
lady right here Nancy she's gonna be shy
on TV she's from North Carolina and
she's helping me a lot and I have to
talk like I understood
around her because she brings out the
southern veil in me Selene when she was
walking by I stole one of Gloria's
necklaces yeah it was a diamond it was
really nice so I'm you know I'm
pocketing things and I'm listening to
Aretha trying to steal some riffs and
things some ideas so it's good kidding
there's no diva drama there's not this
whole thing don't believe it you know
this year Whitney and I recorded to do
it for the DreamWorks soundtrack you
know you know Whitney said it was not a
boxing match how would you describe
definitely not a boxing match I think I
mean this whole project is just so great
to be working with Whitney but more than
anything I think it's great that I made
a new friend Whitney and I our whole
shtick was that we were gonna rip off
the bottom of the dress is like we had
the same for us on people will be
shocked we were together I was in my
trailer literally five minutes before
the show was gonna go on and they're
like MC the dress it's not here and I'm
in my bathrobe like so they got a police
escort and they brought my dress the man
who made the dress actually made dresses
for Marilyn Monroe in the 50s so he came
and fit the dress on me and it's gonna
yeah tight corset that's kind of sucking
the life out of me but it will be
alright
describe this night in one word what
would the word be surreal tabby who was
my stunt double from my last video
heartbreaker where we got into the to
the karate fight she and I are going to
be wrestling in this disgusting bin of
jello just to really toward you myself
because otherwise what would life be in
the videos the Heartbreakers video and
the bad variety good variety and it's
like at this point I want to have
like I don't want to have to always be
here's where I am in the field on a roll
ghost or whatever it's like I'm having
fun for the first half of my career I
didn't even show my forehead because
people told me that I did before I had
all these dramas and insecurities and
now I'm just glad that I can feel more
free and more happy so we've seen me
parodied as you know on Saturday Night
Live with the I get Maria singing with
the hand and yeah after seeing that you
know I used to think I had an on image
but then I realized I guess I do do this
hand movement stuff a lot to have a new
home for the first time and my only the
only home we've ever owned alone cuz I
owned one with someone else before but
that burnt down but I did own it
actually paid behalf of everything too
but nobody knows that it bit you know
what I want I just want to do what I'm
doing be happy and like revel in the
splendor of life and enjoy life and make
every day a fun-filled Fun Fest because
otherwise what's the point you have a
greatest hits CD that comes out today
does it come out today Oh princess tell
me about the look it's kind of like a
combination of harley-davidson meets a
little kind of a hip-hop sexy thought
sexy thug give them a little bit of that
but I'm here with my sis so I had to you
know
I'm representing well it's June and my
philosophy is look it's supposed to be
warm out so I'm just gonna pretend like
it is some people have told me oh you
alienate you know the older women when
you dress like this or then they'll say
oh you're too sophisticated so that's
alienating the younger kids I'm like
what can I just be me all these rumors
please set them straight
are you engaged I'm engaged in
conversation with you right now this
moment there you go I love your hair I
love the dress I love everything I love
your hair and I love a dress and I love
the adventures with Mimi we're going on
an adventure we got emancipated now
honey it's time for adventure my demo
tape was pretty good it had a few
number-one songs on its off I remember
sitting in front of my TV watching the
vision of love video on bTW how do you
do it from there to here how do you
sustain that well first you have to make
sure that the hairdresser doesn't wait
your hair down it's so much product than
that I've never mind I'm not gonna go in
at a darling I do tend to change and I
don't know why but my friends right
hashtag the diva about me my thing is I
have to be myself and if that means in
that moment I hear I don't hear you I
don't see you you don't exist to me at
this moment that's what it is all about
having a dress-up moment what does one
do this is my own edgy like rock star
moment oh the birth of the twins
I had a playlist and they were born to
the Madison Square Garden version of
fantasy so it was applause applause and
I think that just got them because now
helping them on stage and when they have
to leave mr. Monroe is like bring me
back to my mommy this is your very first
et interview what's your first reaction
my first reaction is who did the hair
this would wear pink line I'm obsessed
with it I was so obsessed with me and
goes you've no idea my fans are gonna
have a lot of moments that they're gonna
be like that was a classic that was a
classic when was the last time you went
grocery shopping grocery shopping it's
very bad lighting in the coast people
tell me you go to the grocery store yes
we did ride the subway when I was
wearing a full gown but I mean I just
figured like I hadn't been on the subway
in so long I was like why not do it and
if you're gonna do it do it in a blue
Versace gown we're getting the memoir
soon what's not gonna be darling you're
not ready
no I really mean it yeah revealing um
honest and just a really cathartic
experience that I'm working on it
yeah my last question for you there are
crazy rumors that you are on the masked
singer with Nick is this true bye bro
bye
[Music]